Guten Abend.
Ich bin Ingassis, meine Name.
Heute bin ich die zuständige Ersten auf dieser Station.
Und ich will gerne mit Ihnen das Analysegespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, Herr Doktor.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerensspiele brauchen,
brauche ich ein paar Informationen über Ihre persönliche Daten.
Wie heißen Sie das?
Mein Name ist Hans Zimmer.
Zimmer?
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt 65 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
1. April 1964.
Wie groß sind Sie?
lange nicht mehr, gemessen vor Doktor ungefähr 1,75 Meter war ich mal.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich habe immer das Gleichgewicht, ungefähr 70 Kilogramm.
Okay.
Wer ist Ihr Hauptsatz oder Ihre Hauptsatzin?
Herr Doktor Müller, der hat mich hier überwiesen.
Okay, danke für die Informationen.
Herr Zimmer, was führt Sie uns, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Herr Doktor, wie ich schon sagte, der Haushatz hat mir eine Überweisung gegeben
oder eine Einweisung, dass ich ins Krankenhaus gehen soll.
Und zwar folgendes Problem.
Ich habe seit längerer Zeit Husten.
Und das ist ungefähr seit über 3, 4 Monate.
Wird es mal besser?
Da hat der Haushatz mir auch mal Antibiotika verschrieben.
Dann wurde es mal besser.
Dann kam man wieder.
Wir haben es schon 3-mal Antibiotika probiert.
Jetzt ist es aber so, dass ich jetzt vor 3 Tagen beim Husten noch Blut gespuckt habe.
Und dann bin ich nochmal zum Haushaltsgang.
Dann hat der einen Röntgenbild machen lassen und hat gesagt,
da ist ein Schatten und ich müsste ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Okay.
Sie haben seit 3 bis 4 Monaten Husten.
Wie ist der Husten trockend oder nicht ausfurcht?
Also war unterschiedlich.
Am Anfang trocken, zwischendurch hatte ich auch mal Auswurf gehabt.
Aber ich würde sagen, überwiegend ist der Trocken der Husten.
Okay.
Wenn Sie Auswurf haben, wie sieht der Auswurf aus?
Es gab Zeiten, wo er hell war.
Es gab auch mal Zeiten, da hat der Haushaltsminister auch deswegen
Antibiotika gegeben, als er so gelblich grün nicht war.
Es hat gewechselt.
Okay.
Und haben Sie nur einmal Blut im Husten gesehen?
Ja.
Wann war das?
Das war vor 3 Tagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Aktuell habe ich keinen Fieber, nein.
Leiden Sie Schüttelfrost oder Nachschluss?
Kann ich nicht sagen, nein, kein Schüttelfrost.
Kein Nachschluss.
Haben Sie Schmerzen im Brust oder in anderen Köpfen?
Wenn ich stark Husten, dann tut es hier in der Brust weh.
Wenn ich dann eine Zeit lang über mehrere Stunden Husten hatte,
ich habe auch schon mal Schmerzen gehabt.
Aber jetzt, aktuell, habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen gemacht?
Es ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Okay.
Gibt es ein Auslöser für Husten?
Zum Beispiel hatten Sie Kontakt mit jemandem, der ja ähnliche Bescheidung habe?
Ja, am Anfang hat Hausarzt gedacht, da hatte ich auch mal Corona gehabt.
Aber das war dann zwischendurch besser, aber dann hat es wieder angefangen.
Wie gesagt, das geht schon lange Zeit, seit drei, vier Monaten.
Deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht genau sagen, ob das jetzt durch Kontakt mit jemandem entstanden ist oder nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Sind Sie gegen Corona geübt?
Ja, aber es ist jetzt die letzte Infung war vor zwei Jahren.
So war es.
Okay.
Haben Sie Corona-Tests gemacht?
Ja, ich habe diese Tests gemacht, die ich in der Hase steckt habe.
Und das war negativ?
Das war positiv damals.
Positiv?
Ja.
Okay, wann war das?
Das war vor drei, vier Monaten ungefähr.
Also die ersten Zeit, wo ich auch Husten hatte.
Okay.
Hat sich Ihr Gewicht in der Resteseite geändert?
Haben Sie ab- oder zugenommen?
Kann ich nicht sagen, nein.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Er ist schon weniger als früher.
Also das muss ich schon sagen, habe ich nicht mehr so viel Lust zu essen.
Ja.
Okay.
Zwingen mich zu essen manchmal.
Haben Sie Knoten in der Witwolle bemerkt?
Nein, Verlopptung.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stullgang?
Momentan nicht, nein.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Also manchmal kann ich halt nicht gut schlafen, wenn ich Husten reize habe.
Was kommt schon wieder vor?
Husten Sie auch beim Schlafen?
Also manchmal kann ich nicht einschlafen wegen Hustenreize.
Gibt es etwas, was Ihr Husten legt oder erstattet?
Also der Doktor hat mir zuletzt auch Tropfen aufgeschrieben,
wenn ich die nehme.
Die nehme ich halt nur abends oder nachts ein, wenn es zu stark ist.
Dann ist es ein bisschen besser.
Kennen Sie der, oder?
Code Infos?
Code Infos.
Nehmen Sie dagegen etwas ein, außer diese Tropfen gegen Husten.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben drei verschiedene Anleger.
Sie haben zwei verschiedene Antibiotika eingenommen.
Sonst sind keine anderen Antibiotika.
Kennen Sie die Namen der Medikamente, die Antibiotika?
Also kann ich es nicht sagen.
Das ist nicht schlimm, ich kann mit ihr Haus auskippen.
Herr Zimmern, haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Die Luft wird auch schlechter.
Ich habe jetzt Schwierigkeiten, längere Strecken zu gehen,
weil ich es dann auch Luftnode habe.
Und auch Treppensteigen.
Also ein Stockwerk schaffe ich, beim zweiten Stockwerk muss ich da schon kurz Pause machen.
Das war früher auch nicht so.
Sie haben noch Atem seit drei Monaten?
Ja, ich habe schon immer Atemnode, ich habe auch diese COPD-Krankheit.
Aber seit diesen drei, vier Monaten, wo ich dieses Hustenproblem habe,
ist es auch schlechter geworden.
Haben Sie Atemnode in die Ruche ab?
Also wenn ich mich gar nicht bewege, nicht,
aber wenn ich längere Strecken, schnelle Gehe oder Treppen steige,
dann habe ich Luftnode.
Ja, beide Leuchten.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben COPD.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Krankheit?
Seit 15, 20 Jahren ist das bekannt bei mir.
Okay, und nehmen Sie dagegen etwas ein?
Ich habe schon lange Zeit einen Spray,
als Spiriva, da tue ich zur Kapstbremse,
noch immer in der Halation.
Wie viele Mal dieses Spray?
Einmal pro Tag.
Sonst gibt es eine Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe andere Medikamente.
Ich habe wegen Blutdrucken noch Medikamente ein,
das heißt Candidahtan.
Wie viele Medikamente?
Ich habe sie packen jetzt bei mir,
ich kann mal kurz nachgucken, 16 Milligramm.
Einmal pro Tag, oder?
Einmal morgens, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Diese Medikamente nehme ich auch,
ungefähr seit 10 Jahren.
Haben Sie andere, die haben Krankheiten?
Ja, ich habe auch bei mir,
auch Leberzirose,
festgestellt worden,
viel Alkohol getrunken,
das habe ich komplett aufgehört,
nach dieser Diagnose,
da habe ich noch ein paar andere Medikamente einnehmen.
Wann wurde Leberzirose festgestellt?
Also ungefähr vor 8 Jahren, 7, 8 Jahren.
Sie sind in Behandlung?
Ja, in Leberzirose.
Eigentlich nur im Leberhaus,
als kontrolliert nur die Blutwerte manchmal.
Blutwerte.
Und sind die Leberwerte in Ordnung?
Ja, sie waren in Ordnung, ja, hat er gesagt, ja.
Und die haben Ziópid,
Blutdruck und Leberzirose.
Ja.
Und auch die Medikamente,
okay.
Und außer diese Spiriva kann die sagten.
Und Codemphosphate.
Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente, Regelmäße oder Weiber?
Ja, Osyrolasix habe ich als Medikament noch,
weil ich manchmal so etwas
dicke Füße Beine bekomme.
Aber aktuell habe ich da kein Problem,
ich nehme regelmässiges Medikament.
Können Sie bitte nochmal wiederholen?
Ja, Osyrolasix.
Sie nehmen diese Medikamente,
nur wenn ihr Füße dicke geworden ist.
Nein, das ist nämlich dauerhaft, regelmäßig.
Regelmäßig, okay.
Aber da haben Sie Schwelmen in Bein jetzt,
aktuell?
Sind Sie schon mal aufregt,
oder?
Ja, das ist aber schon lange her.
Ich hatte mal Schilddrüsenkrebs vor 30 Jahren.
Da bin ich operiert worden,
dann hat man noch so eine Radioyotbehandlung gemacht,
aber schon 30 Jahre her.
Nehmen Sie jetzt Medikamente?
Ja, das habe ich vergessen.
Ich nehme auch Schilddrüsen mit.
Kennen Sie Andi dos Lidl?
100.
Sind Sie voll standig geimpft?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich vollständig geimpft bin.
Sie sind gegen Corona geimpft?
Ja, ich habe nicht.
Ja, ich vermute, der Haus hat mal kontrolliert gehabt,
aber kann Ihnen das nicht genau sagen.
Zum Beispiel gegen Grippe?
Gegen was, meinst du?
Gegen Grippe?
Grippe habe ich nicht machen lassen, die habe ich nicht gut vertragen,
deswegen mache ich Grippe im Punkt nicht.
Okay.
Waren Sie in Weste seit im Ausland?
Ich habe in den letzten 2 Jahren nicht.
Okay.
Herr Zimmer, haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, sind keine bekannt.
Okay.
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihrer Lebensgewohnheit.
Waren Sie?
Ja, leider.
Seit wann waren Sie und wie viel?
Seitdem ich vielleicht 17, 18 Jahre alt war.
Also ungefähr in Päckchen.
Früher war es jetzt mehr als versuch, weniger als in Päckchen zu rauchen.
Sie waren ein Packung?
Ungefilmung.
Ja, ein bisschen weniger.
Okay.
Sie haben schon COPD.
Ich empfehle Ihnen mit Trafen aufzuhören
oder zu reduzieren.
Ja, ich versuche zu reduzieren.
Und Sie haben mit dem Alkohol aufgehört?
Ja.
Und wie viele Jahre haben Sie früher getrunken?
Stimmt, 15, 20 Jahre,
wo ich auch harte Sachen habe.
Und wie viele haben Sie getrunken?
Was war unterschiedlich?
Es war zeitlang auch nur Bier.
Zwischendurch habe ich auch Schnaps getrunken.
Es war unterschiedlich.
Die folgende Frage ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drugs?
Ja, ich habe einen Kontakt mit Drugs.
Ich habe einen Kontakt mit Drugs.
Ich habe keine Drogen genannt.
Okay.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familien wissen.
Gibt es eine chronische Krankheit bei Ihrer Eltern
oder bei Großeltern?
Chronische Krankheit, weiß ich nicht, ob das was gab.
Bluthochdruck, Blutzuckerkrankheit,
Bluthochdruck,
Bluthochdruck, der ist dann von Herzensverkürstern gestorben.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Er ist schon in der Welt.
Mein Vater.
Er ist an einer Herzimpacht gestorben.
Er ist ein Herzimpacht gestorben.
Er ist von der Welt.
Lebt Ihr Mutter?
Nein, die ist auch verstorben, die hatte Brustkrebs.
Sie haben eine Schwester?
Ja, eine Schwester habe ich.
Die hat auch Brustkrebs,
aber die ist operiert, hat es jetzt überstanden.
Und noch ein Bruder,
der hat auch mit COPD
geraucht und hat also auch so mit Lungen Probleme.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich bin auch ein Bruder.
Nein, ich bin alleinstehend.
Okay, und leben Sie allein?
Ja, ich gebe allein.
Sind Sie schon in Rente?
Ich bin in Rente, ja.
Ich bin seit 3 Jahren in Vorostand gegangen.
Was haben Sie früher?
Ich war Kfz-Mechaniker.
Auto-Mechaniker.
Ich habe keine weitere Frage.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufilmen?
Ja, ich wollte wissen, was Sie denken.
Ist das Schlimmes?
Das Haus hat gesagt, das ist nicht gut, was ich habe.
Etwas so viel.
Das ist so viel.
Das ist so viel, so viel.
So weit sind v.a.
als die Untersuchenden durchführen.
Okay.
Wenn es etwas Schlimmes ist, Frau Doktor,
ich will keine Behandlung haben.
Ich habe auch eine Patientenverfügung.
Wollen Sie die auch noch haben, soll ich die geben?
Ich habe nicht gut verstanden, was meine ich?
Wenn ich eine schlechte, schlimme Krankheit habe,
dann möchte ich die nicht mehr behandelt haben.
Ich habe auch eine Patientenverfügung,
wo ich das unterschrieben habe,
dass ich auch keine weiteren Maßnahmen haben möchte.
Zuerst müssen Sie nicht die schlimmsten Ursache denken.
Wir müssen die Untersuchenden durchführen
und darüber widersprechen,
was wir haben und was wir machen können.
Wir sind für Sie da, um Sie gut zu behandeln.
Das ist nett, wunderbar.
Können Sie mir versichern,
dass ich, wenn etwas passieren sollte,
nicht an die Maschine gehängt werde?
Ich kann jetzt nichts sagen.
Ich möchte nicht an die Maschine.
Das will ich noch mal klarstellen.
Können Sie mir das garantieren,
dass das nicht passiert gegen mein Willen?
Ja, Ihre Wünsche ist natürlich wichtig für uns.
Ich gebe Ihnen noch mal diese Patientenverfügung ab,
damit Sie das auch noch mal schriftlich von mir haben.
Vielen Dank, Herr Dr.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe eine Frage für Sie, Herr Müller.
Waren Sie in der letzten,
die nächsten Zeitung eines Stationärs in Hamburg?
Nein, wir waren nicht stationär.
Ich habe eine zweite Frage.
Wie viel Kissen war es in der letzten Zeitung?
Normalerweise ein Geschenk.
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Ich habe eine andere Frage gemacht.
Ich habe einen anderen Geschenk.
Ich habe ein weiteres Geschenk.
Ja, gerne.
Aber?
Okay. Guten Abend Herr Oberhast. Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Kurse?
Ja, bitte schön.
Es geht um Herr Hans Zimmer. Er ist 65 Jahre alt, ein Meter 75, 75 groß und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Er wurde von ihrem Haus zu uns übergewiesen.
Er klagt über Zeit, 3-4 Monate, manchmal trockene, manchmal mit Ausfussung.
Er war wegen diesen Husten schon mal beim Hausarzt.
Er hat drei verschiedene Antibiotika eingenommen.
Er hat einen Röntgen-Trag veranlassen.
Der Hausarzt hat eine Schatten im Röntgen gesehen.
Deshalb sei er bei uns.
Er hat auch die Dispneu bei Belastung seit drei Monaten.
Die Frage, wie man sich nachschweißt, schmerzt, Tachikardie oder Pylotationen hat.
Er hat selbst Corona-Tests gemacht, drei Monate, und der Ergebnis war positiv.
Die letzte Corona-Impfung war vor zwei Jahren.
Bis auf Insomnia, die Anamnese sei unabhängig.
Als Vorerkrankung, leide er an COPD seit 15 bis 20 Jahren.
Er hat Arterielehypertone seit sechs Jahren.
Er lebt mit Rose seit sieben bis acht Jahren.
Er besuchlich Medikamente.
Er hat Spiriva, Spray einmal pro Tag, Kandysartan, 6 mg.
Er lebt täglich ein.
Als für Erparationen wurde eine Troideopemie vor 30 Jahren durchgeführt.
Er hatte auch Radiotherapie.
Er nehmt Erdvoxin, 10 mg, einmal täglich ein.
Er sei gegen Corona geimpft, er sei gegen Grip nicht geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese sei unabhängig.
Er sei rach, seit mit 17 oder 18 Jahren.
Er hat eine Packung pro Tag.
Das heißt, umgefahre 47 Packungen.
Er hat für 5 bis 20 Jahre Alkohol getrunken.
Er hat auch ein paar verschiedene Alkohol.
Nach einer Lebesrose bei ihm festgestellt wurde,
hat er mit Alkohol aufgehört.
Drohlenkonsum wurde beinahe.
Laut der Familienanamnese hatte er die Patienten Arterielehypertone
und er hat eine Mio-Kart gestorben.
Die Mutter des Patienten hatte Mama-Karsinamn.
Die Schwester des Patienten hatte Haberbrus, Mama-Karsinamn gehabt.
Die Schwester ist jetzt gesund.
Der Bruder des Patienten hatte COPD.
Er sei ledig und lebe allein und hatte keine Kinder.
Er sei wärtsner.
Er hat als KFC-Mechanik gearbeitet.
Was ist das Diagnose bei den Patienten?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Brunchial-Karsinamn.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen in Betracht Akkota-Exarbation, COPD und Pynomani.
Ich empfehle die Beschwerde folgendem Mass.
Ich werde den Patienten Köpferle untersuchen,
besonders Lungen- und Herzuntersuchungen.
Ich werde die Differenzialgulut abnehmen.
Ich werde eine Sывung-Parameter mit der OP Diagnose veranlassen.
Ich werde eine Brötgern-Torax veranlassen.
Hat der Haus das schon gemacht?
Ich kann diese Brötgern sehen.
Sie können ja auch zu den Befund bekommen.
Ich sehe dann Brötgern.
Wenn ich keine Befunde finden kann,
kann ich eine City-Torax veranlassen.
Ja, alles klar.
Gegen ebenfalls ein Broncoscolli.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie machen Laborwerte.
Sie müssen aufgrund der Begleiterkram des Patienten achten.
Was könnte da ein Problem sein?
Ich muss eine Sauerstoff-Setzung überprüfen.
Ich habe eine Erleichterungssparameter gemacht.
Sie haben einen Broncoscolli aufgrund der Begleiterkram.
Warum müssen Sie bei diesen Patienten besonders aufgrund der Begleiterkram?
Die Patientin hat eine Leberstürmung.
Sie haben eine Erleichterungssparameter gemacht.
Ja, genau.
Der Patient hat ja über Hemoptysen geklagt.
Sie haben gefragt, wie viel das war.
Ich habe diese Frage nicht gestellt.
Wenn es jetzt am Octöre war,
wenn es eine Blutbeinmengung beim Sputum war,
das wäre wichtig, damit wir entscheiden,
ob wir die Broncoscopi machen müssen.
Wenn der Feetblut abwustet,
müsste man das vielleicht machen.
Wie machen Sie die Broncoscopi?
Mit Hilfe eines Schilders.
Sie machen eine flexible Broncoscopi?
Ich werde die Broncoscopi reflektiv durchführen.
Das ist das Einfachste.
Sie haben massive Blutung.
Dann können Sie gleich mal etwas größere Untersuchungen planen.
Wenn Sie eine Broncoscopi machen,
kann man auf jeden Fall flexibel anfangen.
Wie machen Sie das?
Sie dienen Sie den Patienten für die Broncoscopi?
Oder machen Sie das bei Bewusstsein?
Wir machen unter Narcos.
Was machen Sie da?
Ja, die vollen.
Das ist eine örtliche Betäubung.
Bei Bewusstsein?
Es gibt Leute, die das machen.
Broncoscopi ist unangenehm.
Die Patienten betäuben nicht nur örtlich,
sondern auch Analgosedierung.
Zum Beispiel mit Propofol oder miterzuladen.
Dann können Sie den Patienten aufklären.
Wenn Sie das CT gemacht haben,
und den Tumor verdacht haben,
was machen Sie bei den Patienten?
Sie haben gesagt,
Sie würden die Broncoscopi machen, um die Diagnose zu stellen.
Das ist ein sehr guter Problem.
Was gehört dazu?
Wir suchen noch Metastase.
Wie auch CT und Skeletz-Cintigraphie.
Können wir durchführen.
Wir haben auch eine andere Frage.
Was ist das für die Diagnose?
Wenn das Operebel ist,
können wir operieren.
Wir können auch eine andere Frage.
Wir haben eine andere Frage.
Was ist das für die Diagnose?
Wir können Chemotherapie oder Strahlungtherapie.
Wenn der Tumor klein ist,
und Sie denken, Sie können operieren,
machen Sie eine Operation?
Was gucken Sie noch nach bei den Patienten?
Von dem CT-Bild ist das technisch gut operabel.
Operieren Sie solche Patienten in jedem Fall?
Die Patienten sind COPD und derbes rose.
Sie sind diese Komorbite,
die Risikofaktoren.
Was ist das Wichtigerere jetzt in dem Kontext?
Welche Komorbitäten sind wichtig bei den Patienten?
COPD.
Wir können jetzt von dem Punkt arbeiten.
Die Lunge ist nicht so gut.
Wenn wir eine Operation machen,
kann alles schlechter werden.
Sie gucken neben der technischen Operabilität
auch nach der funktionellen Operabilität.
Wie machen Sie das?
Mit einer langen Funktion.
Genau. Und dann auch weiter unter so natürlich auch.
Okay, gut. Das war eigentlich ziemlich komplett und kompakt alles.
Weitere Anmerkungen dazu?
Unsere Kollegen hat gute, anemnisgeçbre getötet.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Kann es sein, metastase, leber, für leber, von leber?
Kann es sein? Ja. Warum fragen Sie jetzt, lieber?
Konnt ich ja, ansonsten, für Äpatitis, Achtjare, Porachjare.
Syrosa mit Karstinom ist häufig.
Leber, z.B. Karstinom.
Kann sein, ja.
Wie häufig metastasieren HCC, also Hepaticella Karstinom in die Lunge?
Jetzt momentan kann ich nicht sagen.
Sehr selten. Gibt es zwar aber sehr selten.
Wie oft sind die Lymphknoten mit dem Kontext per Riturnial,
aber am meisten sind die Lymphknoten und die Glokorie näher.
Metastasierung beim HCC ist selten.
Es gibt auch mal Knochen, Lunge, habe ich auch schon gesehen,
aber ist eher die große Ausnahme selten.
Die Opidemit Corona kann sein, oder?
Die Pferziatagnosen waren alle richtig und gut.
Es gibt ja Patienten mit chronischer Entzündung,
angefangen von Bronzitis über Pneumonie im Wechsel.
Und Blutpfusten kann ja immer mal sein, wenn er z.B. durch die Leberzirose
eine Verstechung der Leber-Synthese hat,
kann ja auch mal spontan gerinnung schlecht sein,
dadurch auch mal beim Husten Blutung sein, kann ja auch sein.
Deswegen die Differenzialdiagnose in zündlicher Veränderung,
sprich Bronzitis oder Pneumonie ist eine wichtige Differenzialdiagnose.
Der Patient hat Konche Rauchersch 18 Jahren,
wenig oder 56 Jahre alt oder normal 18.
Ungefähr 50 Päckys, das ist schon viel.
Also hat man 18 angefangen, ist jetzt fast 50 Jahre der geraucht.
40 Jahre.
40, Entschuldigung.
18?
Fast 50 Jahre der geraucht schon.
Wenn ich durch die Gerächentage so später am Abend.
Der Patient hat gesagt, 65 Jahre alt,
die haben gesagt erste Empführte 1964.
Ja, das war falsch, das war anders, Geburtstatement.
Musst Kollegen hat gesagt, in der FSB,
diese Summulation ist sehr oft.
Ja, okay.